well here we are Charlotte the final
episodes I know your last few episodes
have been a bit of a steins gate wannabe
[ __ ] but june my anti said he's
learned from his mistakes a manger beats
I'm sure them so I'm sure the same thing
won't be completely rushed and full of
pay for the pacing problems we're really
doing it we are really doing yeah we are
really just sending one guard to take
every ability power in the world you
really want [ __ ] joking were you you
[ __ ] Bob with a Kotori bad english
speaking lines from the main character
obligatory random person picked up from
the streets to say English lines are you
Angelo who are you what do you want from
me oh well at least we know you can also
get reception in the middle of the
desert in Africa somehow it's you know
it's moral choice and plundering and
ability user from someone who's using it
for obvious good would have been a very
interesting standalone episode if we
were given the time oh look I have the
power to heal my eye maybe I can heal it
so I can travel back in time so I can
save the people I love no no that's
that's that's that's too easy
oh you know maybe I could just you know
heal my eye so I can see properly no no
no that's that's too easy
oh you know I have a brother you know
he's blind so maybe I can help him see
you again no no stop I'm not here to
make the world a better place that makes
too much sense it's too easy
hey it's Charlotte I know her name's not
Charlotte but that's what I've been
calling her this entire time you've
probably just killed tons of people
collapsing that building Oh are we not
gonna mention that I guess we're in
Italy now no wait Finland no wait
America I don't know what's going on
anymore what is this show even about so
now we're in some city in the United
Kingdom
I wonder what city this could be I from
the looks of it it's probably [ __ ]
Liverpool or something I I don't [ __ ]
know it looks like some [ __ ] northern
place seriously
and you just fix you know I already Oh
God shooting him doesn't work what do we
do
I've got it if we can't shoot him what
just sell its gun it's a goat well that
was that was pretty [ __ ] useless
wasn't it and now that we've gone full
matrix it's time to play which U is your
favorite you do you like darker than
black you neo you edgy Mac edge to you
or my personal favorite booth Hey look
it's pizza sauce Emoto
Chinese version and the final power in
the world is the power of courage yeah
guys the power of [ __ ] [ __ ] power of
courage literally the most overpowered
ability anyone can have because last
time I checked believing in the opie
brave heart of the cards [ __ ] can
stop an arrow traveling to your [ __ ]
face and after all this is journey comes
to an end after being shot by some
random looking Hispanic man wandering
the slums of Beijing with a crossbow who
could have seen that coming
Hey look it's his brother coming down in
a helicopter out the exact exact moment
he got his last ability you've just just
before he was captured somehow knowing
exactly where he was I mean it sounds
strangely convenient but that's because
of a power he plundered it's probably
the power of good luck or the power of
great great great timing that's that
that's probably that's probably it this
this show it's it's not it's not because
of bad writing I guess your friend did
you you somehow kept your stupid name
practical promise and got in the world
you're blowing tonight you won out email
Facebook this vajay I'm sorry who are
you again and as the final credits roll
I have to ask where it went wrong with
Charlotte the show started off with such
great promise with refreshing characters
and a light-hearted take on a
super-powered premise but too long the
way got crushed under its own ambition
disregarding the sudden time-travel
twist that really came out of nowhere
and the plethora of characters that got
forgotten about the show is one of the
worst pay shows I've ever seen even if
the 13 episode
time was too short there doesn't excuse
a couple of episodes at the beginning
that was wasted due to some people who
we didn't give a [ __ ] about and [ __ ]
baseball all leading to an ending with
enough material to fill up an entire
season in a single episode while it was
entertaining at too many points the
plots of the latter half was the
complete [ __ ] of ideas which is
why we should all believe that gin may
yet I can do better next time using the
power of courage guys courage oh gosh
[Music]
hey guys is King okay I hope you enjoyed
that unplanned episode and yeah I was
originally just gonna make a rant on
Twitter but I had too much to say to fit
in just 140 characters if you want to
watch Charlotte's well I watch it on
crunchyroll so you can also go to
crunchy water calm / young Mazzone for a
free fortnight of premium membership and
I know it might seem like I'm the only
doing silly short videos now but I am
working on much bigger projects in the
background so don't worry about that
with my limited time though these are
the only things I can be cranking out in
the meantime but to look out for much
bigger things in the future anyway
that's it for me now so until my next
video I'll see you guys next time